Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radiolab.
Very good to actually be back here talking
to you. Yes, it's been awhile. Yes.
Where have you killed?
Tell those people who might
have missed what you been doing,
what you've been doing. Well,
we just said we just finished our first
mini season of our first spinoff called
more perfect. When are you
going to have part two?
I believe part two is a coming soon.
I don't know now. Not Tomorrow. Okay.
But, but net but not long because we,
yeah, there's there, there are
definitely stories to tell for sure.
And you know, and uh, if you,
if you haven't checked it out,
check it out at radiolab.org/more.
Perfect. We're really proud of it.
Let me rescue you from this
awkward situation by being
back to radio lab where I
will, I'd like to begin
by building a call,
dark green forest makin
towering trees to your left.
Okay. Right. And I,
yeah, I need, I'm a bird.
[inaudible] a lot of birds
actually and a little [inaudible].
So just give me some background
sound. Yeah, birds please.
Birds. Why do like we haven't even
started this, this is what you do.
You give me w like I want
wind birds. I'm not sure.
I'm not like your sound puppet
here, but I can't, how do I,
all right, nevermind this story. You'll
get your sound at some point begins
with a woman or at the time actually,
she was a very little girl who loved
the outdoors. And I mean really,
I love the outdoors.
When I was a little kid,
I would be in the forest and
I just eat the forest floor.
And I know lots of kids do that.
But I was [inaudible] you mean you
got down on all fours and just, yeah,
I would just eat the dirt.
This is Suzanne Simard.
And so my mom always talks about how
she had to constantly be giving me warm
medicine because I was,
I always had worms.
She's a forestry professor
at the University of British
Columbia and might as
well start the story you back when she
was a little girl. Well when I was a kid,
I grew up in the rainforest of British
Columbia and my family spent every
summer, um, in the forest
and her family included a dog named Jigs.
And so in this particular summer when
the event with jigs happened, um,
what kind of jog is jigs by the way?
He was a not a wiener dog. He was a,
what was he a, you don't
know what your dog,
not a basset hound, but um,
he was a Beagle Beagle. Yeah,
he was a curious dog. And
on this particular day,
she's with the whole family.
They're all out in the forest.
It was summertime and Jigs at some
point just runs off into the woods,
just maybe to chase a rabbit, whatever.
Couple of minutes go by and all of a
sudden we could hear this barking and
yelping and we were all like, oh
my goodness, jigs is in trouble.
And so the whole family and
uncles and aunts and cousins,
we all rush up there. Do they
follow the sound of the barking?
And it leads them to an outer,
and when they go in and there is jigs at
the bottom of the road was probably six
feet down at the bottom of the outhouse
pit. Yeah. Where we've all been,
you know, doing our daily
business. Yeah. Fallen in,
he's looking up at us,
quite scared and very unhappy
that he was covered in um
oh and toilet paper. And of course
we had to get jigs out. I mean,
jigs was part of the family and Jen,
she was so deep down in there,
we had to dig from the sides
to Sorta like widen the hole,
basically expanding it from a kind of a
column of a pit to something that's we
could actually grab onto his
front legs and pull them out.
And so we're digging away and jigs was,
you know, looking up
with his paws, you know,
and looking at us waiting and they're
digging and digging and digging them in.
All of a sudden she says she looks down
into the ground and she notices all
around them where the soil
has been cleared away.
There are roots upon roots
upon root in this thick,
crazy tangle. We're sitting on the
exposed root system, which has like,
it is like a mat. It's like, um,
it's just a mass of matter of intertwining
exposed roots that you could walk
across to never fall through. She says,
it was like this moment where
she realizes, oh my God,
there's this whole other
world right beneath my feet.
Jakes had provided this incredible
window for me, you know,
and this digging exculpate to see
how many different colors they were,
how many different shapes there
were, that they were so intertwined,
as abundant, as what was
going on above ground.
It was magic for me. Well, what's
so what's the end of the story?
Did jigs, um, did jigs emerge, emerge?
We pulled cigs out and we threw them in
the lake with a great deal of yelping
and cursing and swearing
and cigs was cleaned off.
But that day with the roots is the day
that she began thinking about the forest
that exists underneath the florist.
And now if you fast
forward roughly 30 years,
she then makes a discovery
that I find kind of amazing.
She's working in the timber industry
at the time. This is by the way,
what her entire family had done,
her dad and her grandparents.
And when I came on the scene in
19 the neat 1980s as a forester,
we were into industrial, large scale,
clear cutting in western Canada,
huge machines, loaders and cats.
She says a timber company
would move in and clear,
cut an entire patch of forest and then
plant some new trees and you know,
my job was to track how these new
plantations would grow and she says she
began to notice things that, you
know, one wouldn't really expect,
like trees of different species are
supposed to fight each other for sunshine.
Right. When you've heard
that. Yeah, absolutely.
I may have to shade each other out. They
shout and they fear, you know, they,
they push each other away
so they can get to the sky.
But she was noticing that in a little
patch of fires that she was studying.
If she had,
say a birch tree next to a first
tree and she took out the birch,
the Douglas for became
diseased and, and died.
There was some kind of benefit
from the birch to the fur.
There was a healthier
community when they were mixed.
And I wanted to figure out why. Well
of course there could be a home,
any number of reasons why, you know,
one tree is affected by another,
but she had a kind of maybe call
it a a gypsy in recollection.
Flashback. Yes.
Cause she knew that scientists
had proposed years before
that maybe there's an
underground economy that exists
among trees that we can't see.
And she wondered whether
that was true. And so
I designed this experiment
to figure that out.
It was a simple little
experiment. Here's what she did.
She went into the forest, got some
trees, Douglas for Birch and Cedar,
and then I would cover
them in plastic bags.
So I'd feel the plant,
the tree in a plastic bag.
And then I would inject
gas. So tagged with a,
with an isotope, which is radioactive.
So these trees were basically covered
with bags that were then filled with
radioactive gas. Yeah.
Which the trees would just
suck up through photosynthesis.
So now they had the radioactive particles
inside their trunks in their branches.
We had a Geiger counter out
there. As soon as we labeled them,
we use the Geiger counter to in ran it
up and down the trees and we could tell
that they were hot. They
were booboo poopoo right.
And the idea was she wanted to know like
once the radioactive particles were in
the tree, what happens next?
Where they stay in the tree or would
they go down to the roots and then what
happens? And what she discovered is
it all these trees, all these trees
that were of totally different species,
we're sharing their food underground.
Like if you put a food
into one treat over here,
it would end up in another tree,
maybe 30 feet away over there.
And then a third tree over here and then
a fourth tree over there and a fifth
tree over there. Sixth,
seventh, eighth, ninth, 10th,
11th all in all turns out one tree was
connected to 47 other trees all around
it. It was like,
it was like a huge network and we were
able to map the network and what we found
was that the trees that were the biggest
and the oldest were the most highly
connected. And so we, you know,
we've identified these as kind of like
hubs in the network and when you look at
the map,
would you see your circles sprouting
lines and connecting to other circles?
Also sprouting lines. And it begins to
look a lot like an airline flight map,
but even more, it's just this
incredible communications
network that you know,
people had no idea about in
the past because we couldn't,
didn't know how to look. It's
definitely crazy. I mean,
you're out there in the forest and you
see all these trees and you think they're
individuals just like
animals, right? But no,
they're all linked to each
other. This is Jennifer Frazier.
She's a science writer and I write a blog
called the artful Amoeba at scientific
American. I like your title. Thank you.
I spoke to her with our producer letters,
Nasser and she told us that this,
this network has developed a kind
of a nice, plenty sort sorta name,
the Wood Wide Web, the the worldwide web.
I mean like the worldwide man,
but it's now the wood wide web.
It sounds a little bit younger.
Fid It would wade with. Yeah,
so this would wind. Is
this just like the roots,
like what she saw in the
outhouse? Oh No, no, no, no, no.
It's far more exciting than that and
sophisticated and interesting and
astonishing. I mean it is,
it involves a completely separate
organism. I haven't mentioned yet.
I mean this is going places.
What creature? Where are we
going? I'm not going to tell you.
I'm going to just go there. I on where
we went and looked for ourselves.
I don't know where you were that
day. Annie McEwin. Stephanie Tam,
our intern and he's our producer.
We'd decided all to go to to
check it out for ourselves.
This thing I'm not telling you about.
We went to the Bronx to the botanical
gardens because we can get so far you have
to travel here in New York to get
to actual green rates. Actually,
there was a beautiful green sward New
York has. And when we went up there, we,
there was this tall man waiting
for us. An expert. Is that right?
That is his name is Roy
Howling at Roy. By the way.
It comes out with the
strange, it's like a rake,
but it has like an expandable, uh, it's
a truffle rake. Bullish an extent. Oh,
listen to that. Oh, that
sounds dangerous. And so wet.
So we're up there in this, in
his old fires with this guy.
So there's an oak tree right
there. It should have some.
And he starts digging with his
rake at the base of the street.
He shoves away the leaves,
he shoves away the top soil.
[inaudible] feel you ripping the reason
I like that. And so now we're down here,
pulled out of route of some
story. It's just getting started.
They're called feeder routes.
We're carefully examining the roots of
this oak tree on our knees with our noses
in the ground. We can't see anything.
I don't, I mean I see the dirt Rod.
You shooting him white yet? You see
anything? I say it's early in the season,
so he says something about that's
the wrong season. I thought, okay,
so this is just stupid.
But then finally you have the Lens.
She gives us a magnifying glass,
you know one of those little
jeweler's glasses handheld.
Have a look here and he hands
it to hand. Wow. You see again,
wait, let me [inaudible]. Oh my gosh.
I do see them. What do you say?
Little white threads
attached to the roots.
Smaller than an eyelash.
Maybe just a 10th the
width of your eyelash,
but white translucent and hairy sort of.
And while it took us a while to see it,
apparently these little threads
in the soil, they're everywhere.
And when you measure them,
like one study we saw found up to seven
miles of this little threading and a
pinch of dirt.
What a pinch. What is thing?
Is it like, is it a plant?
What is it? What kind of creature
is this thing? Yes. What is it? This
is the fungus,
which by the way is
definitely not a plant.
There are some other kind of category,
and for a long time they
were thought of as plants,
but now we know after
having looked at their DNA,
the fungi are actually very
closely related to animals.
They're one of our closest relatives.
Actually now, back in the day,
this all has a history. Of course,
when people first began
thinking about these things,
we're talking in the 16 hundreds they
had no idea what they were or what they
did, but ultimately they figured out
that these things were very ancient.
Because if you look at 400 million year
old fossils of some of the very first
plants,
you can see even in the
roots of these earliest land,
Clinton's see those threads. This
is a really ancient association.
And then later,
scientists finally looked at these things
under much more powerful microscopes
and realized the threads
weren't threads really.
They were actually tubes hollow.
These little tubes to
tubes and the tubes branch,
and sometimes they reconnect.
So there's [inaudible] seem
to be under the ground,
this fungal freeway system
connecting one tree to the next,
to the next to the next.
People speculated about this,
but no one had actually
proved it in nature in the
woods until Suzanne shows up.
And there was a lot of stuff,
skepticism at the time. But
over the next two decades,
we did experiment after experiment after
experiment that verified that story.
And what you're saying, what is this?
Why is this network even? They're like,
why would the trees need a freeway system
underneath the ground to connect and
why would, why would the fungi
want to make this network?
Why are they going to this trouble
of creating this big network? Well,
they do it because the tree has something,
the fungus needs and the fungus
has something that tree needs.
Let me just back up for a second
so that you could, you can,
to set the scene for me. Yeah. When
you go into a forest, you see a tree,
a tall tree. So what is the tree
do? What's his job? What's his job?
It's soaks in. Sunshine takes the
CO2 out of the air. Carbon dioxide,
which has of course carbon
C in it. Yeah, oxygen. Yeah,
and it keeps the sea carbon,
which is science speak for food
that turns that carbon into sugar,
which it uses to make its
trunk and its branches.
Anything thick you on a tree is just
basically a are made into stuff.
Carbon and sugar, the same thing. Yeah.
You can think of the carbon is basically
the sugar that builds the tree.
However, if that's all they had was
carbon, it would only be this tall.
Oh, that's Roy. Again.
He's holding his hand.
Maybe a foot off the ground would be
a teeny tree. It would be smaller.
So if all a tree could do
is get carbon from the air,
you'd have a tree the size of
a tulip. A Floppy Tulip, Huh?
A tree needs something else. And
what a tree needs are mineral
minerals from the soil.
Very similar to the sorts of vitamins
and minerals that humans need.
What kind of minerals does a tree need?
Like nitrogen and phosphorus, magnesium,
potassium and calcium and copper.
Why? What do these do for the tree?
I can a tree stand up straight
without minerals or can it can't? No.
So for example,
Lignin is important for making a tree
stand up straight and Lignin is full of
nitrogen but also compounds like
nitrogen is important in DNA, right?
It's an integral part
of DNA, like crucial.
If I want to be a healthy tree and
reach for the sky, then I need,
I need rocks in me somehow.
Liquid rock you do,
you need the nutrients that are in the
soil and that's where the fungus comes
in.
The fungus has this incredible network
of tubes that's it's able to send out
through the soil and drop water and
mineral nutrients that the tree needs.
I thought I thought tree roots just sort
of did like I thought I always imagined
tree roots were kind of like straws,
like the tree was like already doing that
stuff by itself, but it's the fungus.
It's doing that stuff. Yes.
In a lot of cases it is the fungus because
tree roots and a lot of plant roots
are not actually very good at
doing what you think they're doing.
She says the tree can only suck up
what it needs. Do these, you know,
mostly through the teeny
tips of its roots. And that's
not enough bandwidth. So,
okay, so the fungus is given
the tree, the minerals.
What is the tree given back to the fungus?
Remember I told you how
trees make sugar? Yeah.
So that's what the tree
gives the fungus sugar.
The fungi need sugar to build their bodies
the same way that we use our food to
build our body. So you can't
photosynthesize, they can't take up CO2.
And so they have this trading
system with trees. She says,
what'll happen under the ground is that
the fungal tubes will stretch up toward
the tree roots and then they'll tell
the tree with their chemical language,
I'm in the neighborhood. Um, can you,
will you soften your roots so that
I can invade your root system?
And the tree gets the message and it
sends a message back and says, yeah,
I can do that. Like I can start
softening up my cell walls and uh,
and make room for you.
And then those little tubes
will wrap themselves into place.
The little white thread, you can see
it, the white stuff is the fungus.
And we saw this in the Bronx.
The little threads just
wrapping themselves around
the tree roots and the kind
of
part of the root intertangled
just around the edge. Okay.
And it's in that little space between
them that they make the exchange.
What exchange would that be, Robert?
That would be sugar, mineral sugar,
literally sugar, minerals, minerals,
sugar, minerals, mineral sugar, minerals,
sugar, minerals. And so on. What? I
forgot to ask you something. Pardon?
Yes. Um, if the, if the tube system
is giving the trees the minerals,
how is it getting it? The
minerals? How's it getting them?
Is it just pulling it from the soil?
Well, that's a miracle. That's like,
that is I got to say doing this story.
This is the part that knocked me silly.
We'll be right back. Hello. This
is Ricardo from beautiful Monroe,
New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
of technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Bessie music. I have a new show
remade in America, presented by cafe.
I'm exploring what it's like to
be an outsider in this country.
I'm talking to people
from all walks of life.
People like me who came here from other
countries and people who were born here
but never felt like they totally
fit in like our recent guests,
Cameron Esposito. When
I realized I was gay,
I was at a college where you could be
kicked out of school for being gay.
Join us as we talk about the America
from a totally different perspective.
I'm Jabil run. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab. And uh, so wait,
what was the,
what was the answer to my question about
how does the fungus get the minerals?
Oh, it's, it's a three pronged
answer. What a fungus does,
is it [inaudible] it hunts it mines,
it fishes and it strangles. What,
how the hell I'm not making this up.
In 1997 a couple of
scientists wrote a paper,
which describes how fun guy have
developed a system for mining.
Jennifer says that what the tubes do
is they work their way back and forth
through the soil until they
bump into some pebbles,
these little soil particles,
packets of minerals, and then
they secrete acid and these acids come
out and they start to dissolve the rock
like you're drilling and the fungus
actually builds a tunnel inside the rock
and it can reach these little
packets of minerals and mined them.
Why? If you look at these
particles under the microscope,
you can see the little tunnels
they curve. Sometimes they branch,
they look just like mining tunnels.
This is very like if you had a
little helmet with a light on it,
like I'm a human. Yeah. Maybe not
with a helmet, but yeah, no whiteness.
Seven tubes or something. Yeah.
Wow. And that's just the beginning.
Jennifer told a lot of an eye about
another role that these fungi play and
that's hunter hunter. What
do you like? The plant is
hunting for water or I mean the fungus,
the fungus is hunting the fungus on tap.
Well, how do you meet? How do you mean?
So they're the little insects
that lives in the soil.
He's just adorable little
creatures called springtails.
They're sort of flea sized and they
spend lots of time munching leaves on the
forest floor.
They're called springtails cause a lot
of them have a little organ on the back
that they actually can kind of like deploy
and suddenly they spring way a pie in
the air
in the David Attenborough version.
And if you want to look on Youtube,
he actually takes in nail.
This pin will give you an idea,
hooks it at this little sprinkle and the
sprinkles, and I don't see it anywhere.
It's gone into the air. Then of
course, because it's the BBC,
they take a picture of it.
It's doing like a triple double axle
back flip or something into the sky.
It's the equivalent of a human
being jumping over the Eiffel Tower.
Anyhow, one of the things
they eat is fungus,
but then scientists did an experiment
where they gave some springtails some
fungus to eat.
They sorta put them all together in a
dish and then they walked away and then
they came back and they found that
most of the springtails were dead.
Instead of eating the fungus,
it turns out the fungus ate them
in the little spring tail bodies.
There were little tubes
growing inside those hoods,
and this is what makes
it even more gruesome.
They somehow have a die and don't ask me
how they know this or how they figured
it out,
but they have a little stain that they
can put on the spring tells to tell if
they're alive or dead. When they did this,
they saw that a lot of the springtails
that had the tubes inside them were still
alive. Oh, that's cool. Yes.
The fungus were literally sucking the
nitrogen out of the Springdale springtails
and it was too late to get
away. Nope pulling cake anymore
and then they did experiments with the
same fungus that I'm telling you about
that was capturing the springtails and
they hooked it up to a tree to try to
calculate how much spring kill
nitrogen is traveling back to the tree.
Well 25% of it ended up in the trees
so they figured out who paid for the
murder, right trees.
Is there anyone whose job it is to
draw a little chalk outlines around the
spring inspected
tail is is the,
is the only spring town with a trench
coat and the head of the door? Yeah,
I have even I can go better
than even that. Huh? There is,
they have found salmon in tree rings like
the as in the fish in the tree in the
tree. Well in a way,
how would the hell apparently bears park
themselves in places and grab fish out
of the water and then you know,
take a bite and then throw the carcass
down on the ground. The phone guy,
you don't have to.
It's rained and snowed and the carcass
is seeped down into the soil a bit.
The fung,
I then go and they drink the salmon
carcass down and then send it off to the
tree. [inaudible]
sets evidence of it now, salmon
consumption. I was like, wow,
that's insane. Salmon rings
in trees. That's, it's insane.
I look and beyond that,
there are forests that we are trees
that the scientists have found.
We're up to 75% of the
nitrogen in the tree.
Turns out to be fish food from just
bears throwing fish on the ground. Yeah.
So the you, if you would
take away the fish, the,
the trees would be like
blitzed, hobbled really.
And is it as dramatic in
the opposite direction?
Like the fungus seem to
be given the, the trees,
a lot of minerals at like from the truth
for sake of how much of their sugar are
they giving to the fungus. Ah, well
I asked Suzanne about that like 2% or
0.001% or no. Um, well,
people have been measuring
this in different forests
and ecosystems around the
world and the estimate is anywhere from
20 to 80% will go into the [inaudible].
What? Yeah, 20 to 80% I'll
go into the below ground,
goes down to the mushroom team,
into the roots and then into
the microbial community,
which includes the mushroom team. Yeah.
The point here is that the scale of
this is so vast and we didn't know this
until very, very recently. You have
a forest, you have mushrooms now.
It turns out the bear network and together
they're capable of doing things of
behaviors, forest, real
behaviors that are deeply knew.
We just learning about
them now and they're so
interesting.
[inaudible]
let's say it's times are good.
The tree has a lot of sugar.
I don't really need it all right now.
I'll put it down in my fungi
and then when times are hard,
the fungi will give me my sugar
back and I can start growing again.
What do you mean? Look, fungi will
give me my sugar. It's like a,
it's like it is a cute, it
is like a bank. She says,
we now know the trees give each
other loans. Oh yeah. Back and forth.
Seasonally. They can also send warning
signals through the fungus. Yeah.
So we've done experiments and other
people in different labs around the world.
They had been able to figure
out that if a tree is injured,
it'll cry out in a kind of chemical way,
and those chemicals will then move through
the network in warn neighboring trees
or seedlings.
That's something bad is
happening. I'm, I'm under attack.
There is an enemy in the midst. So if
a beetle were to invade the forest,
the trees tell the next tree over,
here come the Paul revere sort of. Yes.
That seems to be what's
what happens. So you can,
you can see this as like a game
of telephone. One tree goes, oh,
the next one goes, oh, oh,
oh. And then they do snuff.
They start producing chemicals
that taste really bad.
So the beetles don't want to eat
them. We'll go, eh, I don't want that.
What are the spookiest examples
of this, as Suzanne mentioned,
is an experiment that she and her team
did where they discovered that a forest
is warming up, but is it happening all
over the world? Temperatures are rising.
You have trees in this
forest that are hurting.
They don't do well in warm temperatures
and their needles Turnell sickly yellow,
they will send out, oh no, this is not
so good signal through the network.
But also the other important thing we
figured out is that as those trees are
injured and dying, they'll dump their
carbon into their neighbors. So,
so carbon will move from that dying
tree. So its resources, its legacy.
We'll move into the microrisal
network into neighboring trees. Oh,
so it says to the newer, the healthier
trees, here's my food, take it,
it's yours. Or it could be like, okay,
I'm not doing so all, so I'm going to
hide this down here and my, my seal.
I don't know if you're
a bank or if you're in.
So it's not necessarily saying give
it to the new guy. Well we don't know.
I mean again it's a tree. It doesn't,
right. No, I know. I'm just trying to say,
make sure I understand.
I realized that none of these
conversations are actually spoken.
Give it to the new guy. Give it to the
new. But that's what she's saying. Yes.
Yes.
Suzanne says she's not sure if the tree
is running the show and saying like,
you know, give it to the new guy, or
maybe it's the fungus under the ground.
It's kind of like a broker and
decide who gets what. You know,
I don't completely understand. She says,
one of the weirdest parts of this though
is when sick trees give up their food,
the food doesn't usually go to their kids
or even to trees of the same species.
What the team found is the food ends up
very often with trees that are new in
the forest and better at
surviving global warming.
It's as if the individual trees were
somehow thinking ahead to the needs of the
whole forest. So we know that Douglas
Herb will take a dying Douglas for,
we'll send carbon to the
neighboring ponderosa pine. Um,
and so why is that? Like so and I
think that, you know, the whole forest,
then there's an intelligence there
that's beyond just the species.
Wait a second. Wait a second. You
just used a very interesting word.
I know Robert. I have, you know
what? It's 10 o'clock off to go.
Oh, all writing. So interesting. But
I unfortunately right at that point,
Suzanne basically ran off to
another meeting, but hello,
Suzanne speaking. Oh, there
you are. Hi Robert. Hi.
We did catch up with her a few
weeks later when we last left off.
I'm just saying, you just said
intelligence isn't, doesn't,
don't professors begin to start falling
out of chairs when that word gets used
regarding plants? Yes.
We don't normally ascribe intelligence
to plants and plants are not thought to
have brains, but when we look
at the below ground structure,
it looks so much like a brain physically
and now that we're starting to
understand how it works, we're going,
wow, there's so many parallels.
I do find it magical.
I think there is something
like a nervous system
in the forest because it's the same
sort of large network of nodes sending
signals to one another.
It's almost as if the forest is
acting as an organism itself.
[inaudible]
you know th they talk about how honeybee
colonies are sort of super organisms
because each individual bee is sort of
acting like it's a cell in a larger body.
Once you understand that the trees
are all connected to each other,
they're all signaling each other,
sending food and resources to each other.
It has the feel, the flavor
of something very similar.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
special thanks to Dr. Theresa Ryan of
the University of British Columbia, uh,
faculty forestry to our
interns. Tiffany Tam,
Roy Howling at the New
York botanical garden.
Stevenson Swanson there into any mcewen
and Ben a feral who both produces peace.
Thank you. Alright.
College. Okay. It's time.
Time for us to go and,
and lie down on the
soft forest floor. Yeah.
And may hopefully not be liquified
by the fungus and beneath us.
Yes.
Nice final thought. Bye everybody.
Bye. I'm Robert Krulwich.